at this point i'm basically in shock a  violent mob  has stormed and seized the u.s capitol  for the first time since 1814  and i have a lot of thoughts i'm sure a  lot of people do  i feel a great sadness for this country  and also a lot of rage  focused on a select number of our  country's supposed leaders  well i will spend a lot of time  compiling those thoughts there's one  that leaps out and that is that we need  to impeach donald trump  immediately 14 days left of this  presidency is 14 days too long and who  knows how much destruction will happen  in those 14 days both physically and  metaphorically the 25th amendment is too  good for this president  he needs to be impeached and removed  immediately